Let's go next to our caller from the eight
zero three area code. Who is calling today
from eight zero three. Hello David. Hi, who's
this?
Uh, my name is Jean and um, I watched two
of your videos about, um, Bolivia and Venezuela
and um, I see that, you know, you criticize
what you call the Leninist left and um, I've
watched both you and, um, secular talk and
you seem to have different views about us
intervention there, although you know, you
definitely don't take the position of the
neo-cons. Um, so my question is, um, what
are your thoughts on like historical cases
like the U S intervention in [inaudible] in
1973?
Yeah, I'm, I'm against U S intervention in
Latin America. So what I, I don't, I don't
watch any other shows. So what my position
is, I'm against us intervention in Bolivia
and Venezuela. What's Kyle's position?
Um, he's much more in defense of the Venezuela
and I believe in government, although he does
have some very strong criticism of Nicolas
Maduro.
Oh, so and so, and he's against us intervention
there, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. So am I,
um, do you think that Ava Marela is, was a
dictator?
No. Dictator is not the right word, but he
certainly, um, uh, w was not, you know, he,
he's not, uh, the strongest advocate for democracy
that, that Latin America has seen. Let's put
it that way.
All right. All right. All right. Thank you
very much. Appreciate the phone call. Let's
take a quick break. If you're holding, don't
hang up because I will go right back to the
phones after this very short break.